I believe I'm kept capturing the essence
of Chris Brown are you just drawing a
giant penis hey Chris Pratt here with
dave bautista a lot people don't
understand the process of making a movie
like this it's pretty traumatic you go
through a lot wouldn't you say listen
instead of just sitting here talking
about each other
complimenting each other on our amazing
performances in the movie which is what
everyone thinks and I said instead we're
gonna take what is a customary thing for
us to do after the movie and that's the
paint one another how long do we have to
paint these five minutes my meds
we usually paint each other in the nude
so this is a new venture for us but
moving your head so much you're making
it impossible for me Dave he's just a
bad person you know one of those people
who like is just ugly on the inside
I believe I'm kept capturing the essence
of Chris Brown
are you just drawing a giant pants see
guys with really enormous penises always
make jokes my whole smaller penises are
they do note to self
let's make more jokes about how small my
penises warm a left front I'm not used
to painting under this pressure is that
time gentlemen
[Music]
oh man you win it looks exactly like me
oh man you're good at everything
well yeah this has been David crisp and
you've been painting with us tune in
next time for landscapes
[Music]